what's up creative queen x welcome so i
have a youtube channel and what do you
think is the fastest way to grow on it
because i love creating but i personally
think that my channel has been growing
it has been growing every day i am
gaining subscribers but it's not as
quick as i thought it would be ok so you
know first off it's never as quick as
you think it'll be just in general
things always take longer I wish you
know I thought I think I should be way
ahead of where I am too and that and
that frustration is good like that
frustration fuels you'll to do more and
push harder but it's not a bad thing so
don't don't worry that you're not as
you're not quite yet where you want to
be the truth about growing on YouTube or
Instagram or making anything's channels
grow is you speaking your truth you have
it a message that really means something
to you the not even just the words that
you're giving but the emotional convince
like you've actually feeling the words
as you are saying them it's never been
easier to win if people see your video
and they like it they share it no no I
always I'm gonna be honest I always if
you even if you watch my videos you will
see I put in so much effort and so much
love into all my videos I I don't know I
take ages to edit as well I think I
focus more on the quality than the
quantity if you know what I mean
sometimes I post in ten days one video
or it's like that I think Sherlock would
post more videos do you think or I don't
know posting more videos can help
definitely and I believe that the
quantity leads to the quality that the
more that you do the better you'll get
at the skill of doing it the more you
practice me on camera and the more you
practice editing the better you're gonna
get and I wouldn't default to assuming
that what you're putting out right now
is really good like I I think that my
content is amazing and I think that it
sucks you don't want it to be a kick
down and think that you sucks that's
never where you want to be because you
never create anything great from a
position of feeling like you're not
worth it but at the same time people are
watching your video and they're not
sharing it it doesn't mean that a
hundred thousand people are watching the
video but a hundred people maybe watch
the video and they did not want to share
it with their friends they did not go to
Facebook and say you have to go watch
this video so that means you need to
make the video better so you're never
done improving you're never done
improving the quality right so the
quality is good but it needs to get way
better and the more that you make the
better you'll get at doing the thing
it's a crappy conversation to have but
every every quarter or so I look at my
channel and say how can I be growth
faster what how can I use how to do I
put it on Twitter do I put more on
Instagram like how do I grow this thing
and it always comes back to the content
it's making more content that is better
more consistently I do have a question
for you though I love it here we go what
is it about to launch a website soon
okay and I was listening to Gary
Vaynerchuk he was saying that
advertising or doing like Instagram and
paying for advertising and
advertisements what do you think's more
important the reach or the impressions
or the website clicks when you have to
choose a genre I guess the targeting is
gonna be the most important like making
sure you're going after the right people
so what what is that what are you
selling what's the website about or
what's your product or service would
work I mainly do cutting boards um I
used to be a chef a cook whatever you
want to say okay now it's gonna read I'm
on the other end of the chopping block
and yeah I just love creating dude like
the one word you guys were just talking
about create it man something special
about these cutting boards oh it is
handmade cutting boards uh
with each cutting board 10% goes back to
a charity that I looked up they do
reforestation so you know use trees I
want to make sure there's more trees in
the future I love earth man I want to
make sure we're all here we all have a
treatise in Tony's and have some shade
to enjoy cool so so the like targeting
those people targeting the people who
won one care about cooking because
they'll spend more on a cutting board if
it's quality like don't target me I go
and buy the you know I'm the worst like
I don't even cook bubble bye bye for
Nina and we'll end up with some like
IKEA $10 plastic cutting board terrible
for the environment everything right
it's a good man we all have
thing don't target me right so you have
to be super careful who you're targeting
one somebody who cares about cooking and
cares about quality and then to somebody
who's conscious they care about the
products they buy they want to make an
impact they care that some people will
love that given to charity and will pay
more for that and some people couldn't
care less if you give in a charity don't
target those people right you want to
target the people who actually care I
think I think Instagram ads is a way to
go Facebook guides is a way to go the
challenges if you don't know what you're
doing
you could blow your brains out and blow
your budget super quick I think you
should run out of money super fast and
not get any results I think your best
bet honestly is targeting influencers
who are in the space and giving them a
free sample of your board and hope that
they talk about it I think like I've
seen some of your stuff I've got I've
actually watched some of your videos
from your channel I stopped it I watch
it like you're outside your backyard or
trees and you like your I figure all
this more but your stuff is all like see
I dive deep on my friend your stuff
isn't talk I've never heard you say
cutting board once at least the stuff
I've watched is always about like
mindset and growth and that kind of
stuff more than hey I'm a chef and why
you need to use these cutting boards
right maybe I missed it I'm not like I'm
not a deep diver on your set but that's
what I've seen so what I the way I view
my page is like the product the value I
would have been in the marketplace is
motivation man I love seeing people I
got one message so far that's saying
like the stuff I do changes day and that
I felt great to know that my words yeah
change someone else's life or even make
their day better yeah and uh cutting
boards this is what I love to do as well
so it's just like a segue into my
cutting boards man bring so but here's
the thing it's tying them together like
so so it's all one thing like whatever
you whatever your word becomes if it's
create like you're creating your life
through your messages but then you're
also creating food through using your
cutting boards like items so they don't
seem like two totally separate things
tying them together that it's just your
speeches and your stories and your
videos are just an extension of you as
is your cutting board and so making that
connection
but I think because you're so
comfortable on camera like you've got a
really chill laid-back vibe you're not
getting front of the camera like ah got
hi guys and like freaking out I think
you use that to your strengths I think
what what you should do if I were you if
I your skillset and belief system I
would go target all the people who are
chefs or upcoming chefs who care about
the environment and and I'd be looking
at different hashtags like I don't know
if if conscious cooking is a hashtag or
any of those kind of any of those kind
of hashtags that would be relevant and
then be involved with those people like
message them use your video talent here
comment and support their posts and
their work you got me to click on your
profile because you're not even that
active on what I do dude like you're not
one of my hardcore fans you're not
you're not liking I know the people who
are liking all of my posts every single
post right you're there you're in and
out but you're not every day but I got a
I got to make some cutting boards too
but here's the thing here's the thing
I'm not trying to cut you I'm saying no
pun intended like you got me to click on
your account and check out what you were
doing even though your activity on my
account was just okay where if I cared
at all about cutting boards I would I
would look at buying your stuff if you
make the connection a little stronger
right I didn't even know you sold
cutting boards so you hopped on here but
if you did that same thing just rinse
and repeat with people who actually care
about conscious cooking and that kind of
stuff you're active on their community
you're you're responding you're doing
video DMS that kind of stuff a good
chunk of them will then be curious and
if you're gonna give them a free sample
product they'll say yes and hopefully
talk about you on their accounts true I
think I think you'll have more luck with
that it's more of a time investment than
I'm in a monetary investment but I think
I think that's how you win I think I
think you can if you get some good
influencers to talk about your product I
mean your product has to work you know
it's got to be a great I'm assuming by
default it's a great cutting board I
assume that you are you working with is
an awesome charity to work with this is
how I think you're gonna win so find
those people who are making stories and
and only if it like you're only gonna
win by saying things that are your truth
but if somebody's talking about you know
conscious cooking in some way they're
making a new meal and
a conscious way that that is vegan and
didn't kill any lives or whatever and
that that speaks to you you make a quick
DM and say hey Susan you don't know me
but I just I love your message it really
meant a lot to me thank you for all the
work you're doing to help spread vegan
living whatever right yes and and as
long as you can speak truth each time I
think you're just so you're chill vibe
your authentic vote like I think that's
how you end up winning making a lot of
these little videos won a lot of people
and then just making sure that when
somebody clicks through to your IG
profile they know what you're selling
there's some way in it makes it's not
just the motivation in the trees
spirituality stuff there's also a like
hey I also sell cutting boards and we're
working for leaf leaf what was longleaf
Alliance longleaf Alliance okay all of
that stuff needs to be dozen have to be
in every post but it should be if I'm
looking at your IG page I see that
coming out and if I know you like you
and and you're on the same vibe as me
like I'm talking about the longleaf
Alliance and this isn't this is so
outside what I do
yeah right yeah where if I was in it you
can make the same connection with other
people who are in it and they'll want to
support you and be a part of your
mission yeah I can't see you but I hear
you so okay fringe so I want to know you
think about it when you have to work in
two languages I like the concept because
it allows you to reach more people my
fear at the beginning for you is that
you spread yourself too thin Lee and you
do neither of them as well as it could
be which is for my web TV where I'm but
it's taking me so much time because I am
now doing live in you know evening it's
it's English and at midday it's French
I'm kind of I love it but it's really
taking I
to add two more hours in my day to be
able to keep up with the Instagram thing
you know and yeah I mean honestly if if
I'm you I would spend those two hours on
making the English Channel crush before
moving to another language yeah I think
it's a great idea I think it fits your
long-term vision for what you want to do
but I think the time is it's not the
best investment of your time if you
could be going growing your English
Channel and picking up tons of steam
momentum around that I would rather
spend my time there than worrying about
French yet if I look at my youtube
channel I'm just now testing going into
the Spanish market with dubbing videos
and in the French market with AI and
dubbing videos after we hit you know 1.3
million subscribers I still think
there's tons of room to grow it's still
not my main priority I'm still focusing
most of my efforts on the YouTube
channel but I think this happens to
entrepreneurs not even just multilingual
just even splitting direction between
networks like do I go to YouTube do I
spend time on Instagram but I spend time
on Twitter or Facebook or medium or
snapchat or any of the other ones do one
thing really really really well build
your base turn it into something really
special and meaningful and then
experience the next yeah and the French
one will be there it's it's not dead
it's just not right now if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe it you
act like I am Tulsa what a whale out of
handcuffed lightning throw thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 4 days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident
it's absolutely
we check out the link in description
below to get access